Je surkiffe Pokémon !
Non franchement, surtout les 151 premiers.
J'adore !
Et franchement je trouve que...
Il y a un truc un peu comme des animaux.
Tu vois ?
C'est ce que je me disais au début.
Sauf que finalement, de moins en moins tu vois ?
Parce que les combats d'animaux... C'est pas très légal.
Et puis on ne mange pas un Pokémon
Et un animal, on lui donne une vraie identité, on lui donne un nom.
Alors que les Pokémons, leur nom c'est le nom de leur espèce finalement.
Pikachu c'est Pikachu
En même temps c'est tous les Pikachus
Attends mais si du coup les Pokémons ont un statut inférieur aux animaux...
Ils sont quoi alors ?
♫ [générique] ♫
Du coup par rapport aux combats entre les Pokémons et aux liens qu'on a avec les Pokémons,
on pourrait dire que les Pokémons ont un statut inférieur aux animaux.
Notamment parce qu'en plus ils sont utilisés en plus pour faire des tâches.
Par exemple, générer de l'électricité.
Je ne vous ai pas menti.
Et puis ils sont aussi utilisés pour faire des déménagements par exemple, ou creuser des tunnels.
En fait les Pokémons sont exploités par l'Homme.
Eh mais c'est des esclaves en fait !
Non franchement on dirait trop des esclaves.
On dirait presque qu'ils sont faits pour ça.
Non parce que quand on a des petites tortues qui crachent de l'eau et qui sont prêtes à être pompiers...
A quel moment on peut refuser en fait ?
En tout cas je pense que c'est ce qu'aurait dit Aristote.
Parce que pour lui les esclaves, étaient faits pour être esclaves.
Ils étaient esclaves
Par nature.
Et c'étaient même mieux pour eux qu'ils aient un maître.
C'est ce qu'il dit dans "La Politique", et c'est un peu comme pour certains Pokémons finalement.
Je pense notamment aux Pokémons qui ont besoin de l'affection de leur dresseur, et de bonheur
pour évoluer.
Pour continuer sur Aristote,
et si on modernise un peu, il dit que
si les machines pouvaient marcher toutes seules, on aurait pas besoin d'esclaves.
Alors lui il le dit en mode ça arrivera jamais, on aura toujours besoin d'esclave.
Mais en fait, il le dit pour prouver la nécessité des esclaves.
Sauf que l'histoire lui a donné tort et raison à la fois.
Déjà avec l'industrialisation, on a eu ces machines qui marchaient toutes seules.
Et ensuite l'esclavage, il a été aboli aussi et parce que, justement cette industrialisation,
l'a rendu économiquement inutile !
Donc en fait il a eu tort, parce que non les esclaves ne sont pas nécessaires,
mais il a eu raison parce que sa connexion logique s'est vérifiée.
C'est exactement ce que dit le matérialisme historique de Marx.
En gros pour lui les forces productives, donc l'état des techniques à un moment donné de l'histoire
Sont vachement liées aux forces de production
c'est à dire les classe sociales. Qu'elles déterminent aussi.
Bon, on est parti super loin.
Mais, le truc c'est que quand tu regardes Pokémon
Tu ne penses pas à l'asservissement
Parce qu'en fait les Pokémons, globalement ils ont l'air de kiffer.
Or un esclave qui kiffe son environnement,
Est-ce que ce n'est pas plutôt de la domestication ?
Alors, je te parles d'un point de vue philosophique
Parce que oui, un esclave même s'il kiffe être esclave,
sur le papier ça reste un esclave.
Mais avoir sa volonté et sa condition qui concordent
ce n'est pas pareil.
En fait, le truc c'est que les Pokémons, ils sont plus dans une forme de contrat social.
C'est-à-dire qu'on les nourris, on s'occupe d'eux, on les fait monter de niveau.
Et eux en échange, ils se battent pour nous, on peut les utiliser, etc.
Mais le truc, c'est que l'asservissement
ça n'a jamais vraiment marché
Il y a toujours eu soit des échecs soit des abolitions.
Et la domestication, la vraie, ce n'est pas quelque chose qui se perd en une génération.
Or, il y a bien des Pokémons qui sont domestiqués.
Donc, habitués à l'Homme avec un contrôle de la reproduction, etc.
Mais, ils se dé-domestiquent comme ils veulent en une génération.
Ils sont capturés
serviles, etc.
Et dès qu'ils sont libérés, ils vont dans la nature
et ils se débrouillent comme des chefs.
Comme par exemple, le gang des Carapuces.
Ceux dont on parlait tout à l'heure.
Donc on ne peut pas vraiment de domestication non plus.
Et puis en plus, il y a des Pokémons qui ne font absolument pas ce que le dresseur demande.
Genre Pikachu, il ne veut pas rentrer dans une Pokéball.
Et les Pokémons ont déjà tué des Hommes.
C'est ce que l'on apprends dans "Lucario et les mystères de Mew"
Que je n'ai pas vu !
Et ils disent que dans les anciens temps, il y avait des guerres
et que les gens utilisaient des Pokémons.
Je parle de vraies guerres, je ne parle pas de tournois
Je parle de guerres avec potentiellement des morts humains.
Donc c'est très difficile de faire rentrer les Pokémons dans une case.
Parce que ils sont ni esclaves ni domestiqués
C'est ni des animaux pour l'Homme
En fait, ils ont un statut  totalement inédit
et c'est ça qui rend le monde des Pokémons si intéressant.
Au final, c'est très difficile quand on creuse un petit peu le sujet
de trouver une preuve de l'infériorité du statut des Pokémons
face à celui des humains.
Hormis le fait que l'on en ai créés
et c'est déjà pas mal...
N'hésitez pas à vous abonner pour ne rater aucun épisode !
Et à lâcher en commentaire ce que vous vous avez pensé de tout ça.
Parce que c'est juste un truc personnel
sur un côté, un sujet de Pokémon.
C'est hyper large on aurait pu parler de pleins de choses.
Et il est fortement possible qu'il y ai certains trucs que j'ai dis sur lesquels vous soyez pas d'accord.
On se retrouve dans deux semaines, jeudi 18h où je vous envoie du Love et de la Peace
*SMAC*
[voix grave] YALLAH ! YALLAH !
♫ musique de fin ♫